welcome back to the warlord podcast i'm
james marshall
roll the intro
oh what aladdin what a jingle and
speaking of lads today i have one of the
most
requested lads out there on the show
he's been a legend of new zealand rugby
playing for the wellington
lions the hurricanes and of course the
mighty all blacks he then moved over to
gloucester in england where he dominated
over there
and now he's back in super rugby playing
and carving up for the mighty force
along with all that rugby stuff
throughout his career he has been an
absolute lad one of the best lads in the
game it is
jeremy thrush welcome thrushy cheers
jimmy
great intro thanks mate boy firstly how
good is that mo
i knew it was going to be good but not
that good that's the best i've ever seen
yeah it kind of took growth last year a
little bit when we were in isolation i
grew a beard
uh the wife was pretty sick of it to be
fair and kept asking when i was going to
shave there's a fair few silvers growing
through it so
i came out with this and she wasn't too
happy about it so that's been there ever
since really so it's been um
it's been pretty good well it's still
with me so i must be doing something
right
what's the plans with it any any plans
no
not really um just keep growing it
there's a few silvers coming into it
yeah which is uh
a little bit disappointing but no it's
just i don't know so just quite enjoy
having i get a few
good comments from from guys saying
that's a good mogu
yeah but the wife and most girls or
women i talk to just
brush it off pretty quickly so it's
probably a good thing oh you've
it's obviously built you some sort of
cult following over in
perth because man i've had so many
messages from people over in perth
wanting to get you on wanting to know a
little bit more about you because
people are just loving you over there
that's good
is that a stitch up nah this is genuine
the force field
oh really i don't know
i don't know what i've been doing i've
been doing too much to be fair but
and the season for the force hasn't gone
completely to plan so far but
it's not over yet no no no well we're
better than last year so far
we've got one went under the belt so
hopefully uh we can improve on that
we've got what three more games
tars reds rebels so um hopefully we can
uh
yeah notch up a few more wins on the way
and you just have to finish
third really in this competition and you
and then you get a
crack at playing a semi-final in a and
then onto a final whoever finishes first
that's true
what is that uh was it semi-pro where
they third place
so uh yeah that's i guess that's where
we're aiming at this stage is
sneak into third and go from there nice
and you've got big tony lewis on your
side now so
surely things are going to start
happening for you well that's what it
sounds like that's what uh
that's what everyone's been telling me
that uh he did good things with
the the marcos down there so um
hopefully can help
sort ourselves out over here and get us
going in the right direction
and looking to resign you of course oh
definitely
of course of course um hold on to the
hold on to the old battler
for another year hopefully you'll be
good how is the body feeling because
you're looking about 25 out there
you're running around like a spring
chicken are you feeling young
yeah i feel pretty good um obviously a
few
few niggles i've had ankle and
shoulder cleanups last in the off season
but
they've been going all right i think the
weather helps it's a lot
warmer and nicer and you see the sun a
lot more than you did in gloucester in
the uk so
um get down to the water in the beach a
fair bit which which helps which helps a
lot so it's good yeah
no doubt well anyway we've got heaps to
get through and also
you've got about 300 questions coming
for you too so we'll crack on
and we'll go back to the start with you
so um take us back to what life was like
for you growing up i understand you were
born in auckland which i didn't actually
know but
um tell me a little bit about what your
life was like yeah um
yeah so yeah born in auckland um
lived out in pepakura until i was about
five um and then had a i guess a bit of
a different uh
upbringing from most kiwi lads um we
moved to
canada for five years so
we lived over there and uh just out of
toronto
um and we lived there for five years
played played a bit of soccer
played some ice hockey and
dad was affiliated with a club over
there so he's sort of set up with
another
expect um like a kids touch on a
saturday morning so played a little bit
of touch footy over there um
it was uh it was pretty good it was
pretty good it um wasn't very good at
the ice hockey couldn't stop um it
wasn't it was not
it was supposed to be non-contact but i
couldn't stop so either hurt myself
falling into the side of the boards or
just falling over everyone else so
i remember pretty uh early on playing
you know like when you first start
playing rugby though like
someone asked when you're young oh yeah
you quit and they're like yeah we'll
just
chuck them on the wing because yeah you
know like you don't have to learn too
much
so i ended up goalkeeper quite quickly
because i didn't really have to move too
far
so i've played a bit of goalkeeper i
remember the last year if i wanted to be
the goalie for a while
so now that i look back i was like
obviously because i was pretty crap and
couldn't
couldn't stop or anything so that's
where they put me why couldn't you stop
it's just quite hard you know like
you're going to have to like put your
escapes to one side a little bit you're
like sharp and
oh true i don't think i had the balls to
actually do it i just kind of just
stumbled my way into someone else on the
on the side of the boards quite quickly
to be able to do it really
it took me forever to learn how to do it
so yeah that was pretty it was pretty
cool it was good fun and then
yeah about oh it must have been almost
11 we moved home to new zealand and
to wellington and yeah grew up until
until i left till um to move to
gloucester so i
went through all my school or most of my
schooling back home
um and then yeah i went and joined the
academy and stuff like that and
kind of took off after that so is that
when you got into rugby basically when
you moved back to
new zealand is that where it started for
you yeah i used to
there was touch in canada yeah i was
like the youngest who played and dad
used to get pissed off because i'll just
go
down the back and like pick the flowers
and play around out the back and
piss around and so i didn't do too much
there and didn't play too much but
came back to new zealand and yeah made
me play i was too big to play for the
under-12s
for the eastbourne team so i went to
harlboy's marist and and joined
join that club so it was pretty cool
actually because everyone that was
i played for that year when i went to
high
my school at the high school all those
guys
that have gone through that team i
played for there
were playing um at haha so and yeah a
few familiar faces when we went to high
school so that was it was pretty good so
yeah played rugby all the way through
high school and then didn't really think
too much of i wasn't really a big kid or
anything but then
i guess last year's school things sort
of kind of
took off a little bit more and got
picked for a few teams and then it kind
of moved on from there
is that when you had your growth spurt
because you're obviously a massive unit
now so when did you grow
yeah i was always quite tall but like
real skinny and lanky oh yeah
had nothing on me and then yeah probably
in a sixth form going to december form i
got a little bit bigger and
wouldn't say filled out it took me
forever to fill out a bit more um
but yeah seventh form kind of made
wellington secondary schools and then
someone said that i was in a chance to
play for the
hurricane schools and then from there
like was pretty surprised
got picked for new zealand school so
obviously was doing something right or
there was no one else around at the time
i could really pick from so
yeah but like i never really got like
big till
probably my second third year in the um
wellington academy i was on like a
pretty big um like eating regime all
through that to put on some weight
because i battled to get over 100 kgs
for a long time
yeah was it always your goal to play
rugby it sounds like your dad was a
pretty big influence on your rugby
career too trying to push you towards
rugby was it always your goal to sort of
make it a profession
um no no like
when i was i guess like you just i just
had good friends that
we used to play half the school play
touch all the time um
and then i got to play with them all the
way through school which was awesome
um our last year for the high school we
were in a very strong
uh rugby school to be fair and then our
last year at school there was a group of
us that would have gone through school
together
and we made the top division of the
first 15 competition and we lost in a
semi-final to
welding college by only like three three
odd points i think um
and that was pretty cool i still have
good memories of all that but it was
never really
until probably 7th form when i got asked
to join the academy i kind of just
thought well you know
give this a good crack and see what
happens um yeah
i probably would have left school if it
wasn't for rugby i was just kind of sick
of it wasn't
really enjoying it probably would have
had a trade or something done a trade
but
mum didn't let me leave so i had to stay
in there and i'm pretty lucky i did
because
i had some pretty good times through
school so yeah yeah i'm glad mom didn't
let me leave school
and what a career you've ended up having
geez what a great call from
so you must you must have been pretty
impressive in your um once you got
selected for that new zealand schools
team because then you obviously went on
to make
new zealand under 19s as well and had a
pretty good world cup
over there by all accounts yeah yeah
yeah
i guess things sort of just took off
yeah yeah played
schools and then came back and then most
of those you know how it is most of
those guys that played the schools get a
call into um that was it was under 19s
back then camp and
trial pretty well through that and was
lucky enough to get picked and go
we went to durban for the for the world
cup and it was yeah first experience
kind of
or obviously being in south africa but
experiencing
sort of rugby in a in another rugby mad
country and it was
it was pretty cool it was pretty unreal
um time and we're fortunate enough to
to win it um and we had we had some
great great players some really good
players in that team
um karen reed was there and he was
unreal i don't think he missed a tackle
through the whole competition
i think he played every game on every
minute and he was just
yeah he was we just had some really good
players that just
yeah it was awesome to be a part of you
had some good players but there was
only one under 19 player of the year
jeremy thrush how was it winning that
award
um yeah it was a bit of a surprise i
i think it was i scored a try in the
last three games so i'm not sure
um obviously got a couple of lucky
offloads i didn't really do much
for them to be fair it was more everyone
else do it and i just backed myself with
just being really fit yeah like i used
to run a lot and
stay pretty conditioned and just yeah
just my support plan was i guess a
big part of my game going through
through the through the ranks and
um yeah just got a few offloads off a
few boys and
and finished them off so i'm lucky
enough to
to get that but it was a it was a hell
of a trip we got flown all the way to
london for the awards um the
said african like men's team were
team of the year that year and we had a
hell of a [ __ ] dig afterwards with them
i remember ending up in
i don't know whose room it was but they
were just bringing trays of heinekens in
like
i should remember like shocked burger
like bucky's bothered back to matt field
we're all just tackling each other like
in the room i was like
it was pretty cool was awesome did you
tackle any of them in the room
no i honestly was like at one stage i
remember like standing back and thinking
like
jesus what the hell am i doing here like
what's going on
this is not like one of those moments
where you're like holy [ __ ] like
um but then yeah i just kept getting
stuck in and i just remember
like hotel staff drinking prospering
trays of heineken beers and like
trays and trays it was a good time oh
that's classic
and when you won that award did you feel
some sort of um did you feel like
there's an expectation on you to
sort of kick on from there because i
mean there's some pretty massive names
who have won those awards throughout the
years once you won that did you feel
like things were going to start
happening pretty quick or how did you
feel once you'd won it
i don't know yeah i don't know i've
never really
i guess thought that too much
i kind of like just was just like yeah
like i obviously had
goals again i was like okay well let's
try to make
the under 21s and check on with
wellington a little bit
um got two years with them new zealander
21s which is
pretty grateful for that and pretty
lucky i think to get in that first year
um and then came back and got asked to
join the lines
and the end of 2004 i got us to join the
lines just as like an apprentice
training um go in and hold a tackle bag
but it was
a hell of an experience to go do that
and then i didn't have real big like
thinking okay like
i've got to do this i've got to do that
i just trying to cruise through i think
within my mindset just yeah just keep
trying one higher one higher i guess
yeah
how was and how was it going into the um
wellington lions
setup obviously you're pretty young guy
and it
seemed like a pretty intimidating team
to be going into at a young age
um yeah i was yeah
that 2004 2005 year pretty nervous i
remember the first
gym session i did i like ricky flutie
took me around and did it and
he was a hell of a character but like
the whole time
like i think it was just his personnel
and the way he goes about things but i
was like i'm not sure if this guy's
trying to take the piss out of me or not
but just the way he was going about like
the german
thing and like you know i was just like
okay like this is what we're doing here
but it was good i expected in your head
the all blacks came back to play
um so you had a lot of you know
experience there's a lot of
um big name abs like big name super
rugby players um
you know there's a there's a lot of
people to look at and watch and and pick
up on things but
it was a great group there was a lot of
guys um
that kind of took a few of us younger
boys under their wing a little bit
and just helped us out um like the likes
of luke andrews like
been hearing joe metz and i was like all
those kind of guys
who are just great with the young boys
um us coming through and
yeah definitely owe a lot to to those
boys and how they how they looked after
you know like a 20 21 year old coming
through um
and into that environment it was it was
great yeah and you and you played 87
games for wellington line big numbers
um any any standout games or memories
that stand out to you
throughout the wellington lions career
uh on the field
ramsey shield winning the rampage shield
up and up in auckland and
2008 i'd have been i think 24 years
since wellington had done it um
so that was that was a hell of a
experience and a hell of a
weekend and week especially up in
auckland beating auckland up there um
to get it was pretty pretty cool and
then
a hell of a lot of good um into your
dues
on a sunday uh sunday sessions um
i was fortunate enough like the it was
like three or four years that we made
the final and we just couldn't get over
the line but
i just thought that's what it was about
you know i mean you play for wellington
you're
you're there and there abouts and you
you you're winning you're close to
winning things that you're going to go
on and when things so like
those first four or five years i you
know it was just pretty unreal
um just like being in finals or playing
and winning around for the shields and
stuff like that was
was pretty cool and you obviously had
some pretty uh good times off the field
too up there i got a lot of questions
about
the old stark mansion want to talk to me
about that one oh
yeah there was a hawani um
who else you stand there's a few boys
that had this place
i guess it was in between island bay and
uh lyle bay around there
and it was up on the hill and yeah it
looked like
a stark mansion from the iron man hi
yeah it's pretty unreal um we had a fair
few good shindigs
i'm pretty sure we even had a quality
there
that was pretty good but yeah we had
some good nights you get up on the roof
as well as like just a straight flat
roof
um so boys brought the drone out and
there's some
yeah we had some pretty good uh pretty
good nights there in the last year
before
before we went moved on it was pretty
good
yeah no doubt and then let's talk to me
about your hurricane's career as well
how was that
when did that sort of happen when did
you make your first hurricane squad
uh when you were 2007 uh i was wide
training group
and i think we had a fairly big
group that year because that was when
they did the the world cup they did that
like they wouldn't really get to the abs
boys at the start of the year yeah
so it was like a big we had like a big
squad and then
a pretty big wide training group as well
but and then
2008 was my first year yeah
i had a pretty good year in 2008 but i
like i'll probably say the credit
came in like i did a whole preseason
with the hurricanes and to um
playing club rugby in wellington but
like training with the canes and then
going into
an itm so i was pretty fit and i got
myself a pretty good
nap to kick on for that next year and um
get a chance to play for the hurricanes
and get picked so
um which yeah i think like that 12 month
training base definitely made a
difference going into that that was an
eight year
and plan for the gains and then when you
got your crack you obviously made an
instant impact a massive shift from you
early on on your debut off the bench
yeah um i remember my first game
we played waratahs it was uh
when cj got knocked out remember um he
went to charge down the falcon
he got knocked out with the ball yeah
you know jason eden we had um some
pretty good locks
back then playing for the canes and then
got another chance in
uh victoria to start against the bulls
and we
doesn't it doesn't happen very often but
i think we we put almost 50 on them that
game
um and then yeah just things kind of
kicked on from there i just got a chance
to start
um every game from then on and um we
lost
the crusaders in the semi-final down
there unfortunately then they went on to
win it so
yeah but it was even a lot better now i
remember the
warrior cars going around playing the
bulls game that's about it really
i think there was a there was a game on
tv the other day it was the crusaders
um hurricanes uh semi-final and i
started watching it and i was like cheap
it's like
like you'd think you played a right game
and you look back and you watch it
yeah i was up to nothing and then
somehow that's how
i made a career running around doing not
too much
somehow somehow i got through still
going
it's still going 15 years later
but how was your memory have you did you
have many head knocks throughout your
career you seem to have
a pretty good memory um yeah not i had a
couple of little ones like not
fully knocked out the worst one i had
where i got knocked out was we had a
test
match and joburg um against south africa
and
ran into tried to tackle dwayne van
muehler and
got the side of his hip and yeah that
was it got boom
out to it and that's the only one i've
really enough wood that i've actually
really had that's
put me out and i've blacked out so i've
actually been pretty lucky that way it
shows that i don't really
put my head into these places like this
just stand around and watch a few racks
and
hold onto a few people's legs no you use
your hard parts very well
you obviously paid 110 games for the
hurricanes
huge achievement most kept lock in
history for the hurricanes
um the legendary lock any standout
moments one that stands out for me
was your try against the cheaters one of
the greatest tries you'll ever see
talk me through that one yeah
what year was that i'm going to say i'm
going to say 11 because i wasn't in the
squad then i remember
getting up and watching it jeremy
thrashing my fantasy rugby team
come on jeremy run some meters here he
goes
yeah i remember every game we ever
played against the cheaters was real
high score
both teams just didn't want to defend
yeah but um
i remember is getting the ball down the
sideline and had carlsey on the inside
and it was
i was one of the cheaters by the backs
or
loose forge was kind of just hanging out
and i just kept
looking like i was going to pass the
causey and got about
i must have got it i don't know maybe 30
odd meters out maybe i don't know and
then
got just inside the 22 and realized
[ __ ] i think i can do this myself i
don't have to give it you have to give
it inside
and put it down and was exhausted it was
like i think it was the last play of the
game
like lay down and the boys jumped on top
of me and then like got up and
gave it the old hot dog tested in the
hurricane
swirl and all that and giving it
everything but
yeah i didn't get too many tries but
that one was
it was pretty good and we got the win
from it
and we were in a pretty tough place yeah
yeah that was good
one thing i do remember is tyson keats
walking around the change rooms after
the game
just walking around singing we are back
we are back
from the hangover you just kept
we had a hell of a good night i think
after that one as well we needed it yeah
oh i bet any other memories that stand
out throughout your career
at the hurricanes um yeah i've made some
pretty good years
making some uh semi-finals early on in
the career
obviously a few tough years there but um
2012 was a pretty good year for us um
our last year 2015. i know we didn't we
didn't win it but
um that was a hell of a year i felt
pretty
pretty proud of where we got to through
through the tough times we'd had
um leading up to that um i think from
where we were
and where we where we wanted to get to
um when things kind of
didn't go that well and we i guess
people call it a rebuild but we were
trying to
change the way the hurricanes were
perceived
to get to where we were in 2015 and then
see the boys kick on in 2016 was was
pretty good and
i you know pretty proud of like the
development that
came through that team and how much more
professional i guess and
how much i guess more respect we had
from other teams um
getting to that point and i think still
where they are now seeing them obviously
they've had a private rough start at the
moment but
some good players in that team and their
quality quality group moving forward so
yeah pretty proud of where we got to and
and the development of players within
that group
um it's probably a big thing without
obviously winning any
silverware myself yeah so talk to me
about the 2015 final it's obviously been
a massive
moment in a lot of guys career who i've
had on the podcast
um both highlanders and hurricanes so
talk to me about your thoughts leading
into that one and after it how did you
feel um
leading into it like remember um plum
john plum tree like when we first
started we never
we never talked about really winning
winning it but he always used to put the
picture up of the stadium full remember
he's like before every meeting and
everything he always used to
put like the stadium and that was like a
big thing it was like we're going to
bring the crowds back we're going to
bring
um people into the stadium and like
obviously byproduct of that is winning
games and
and we did you know we did that and i
think that was like i thought it was
awesome like we didn't put like a
maybe we should have put an outcome on
like a process of
this plums
um but no i just thought that was really
cool yeah i thought like without even
thinking about it i was like yeah that's
what we're gonna do and
you know we won games and got there i
remember getting the final and
obviously i was pretty like we're all
pretty nervous i think but like i i
don't remember a lot of it i just
remember like
nx being like and just before half time
thinking like
okay now this is this game is all over
the place like it just
you just it just felt hectic like the
whole time like
um and it was it was so quick like and
it was just like
one at one stage like whatever the ball
would be like on their 22 or inside
their half
i'm inside their 22 like and the next
minute they'll be like
counter-attacking and being like and
we'll be back on our own i just remember
like being like
what is going on this is all over the
show like this is
unreal and then yeah just
i haven't even watched it properly um
i don't know i just feel like a few
things didn't go away we
like we had that pivotal moment i think
in the second half when we went for a
mall and they didn't
they stood off and came around and like
almost took the win of our sails i
remember that like that little bit of it
um and then yeah i just it was just one
of those games i felt
it could have gone anyway like i didn't
you know i didn't feel any
time that we had a lot of dominance or
they had a lot of dominance it was just
i guess they kind of capitalized on a
few moments they had
at the right time and and got some
points and
um yeah they just got over the line yeah
it was
i still i still what i do remember of it
it was like
any time i played for wellington in a
final or semi-final
with the hurricanes my mom and dad would
come and we'd always
we never won so i remember that week
thinking to myself like they look and
they lived up north i remember thinking
yeah like
just they're not going to come like i'm
just going to tell them they can't count
that's that hard
having this hoodoo thinking like they
stay at home they watch on tv like
they'll be happy if we win
like this is all good because i know the
thursday or the friday like
find out that like my sister's coming
down like with her husband
and mom and dad are coming down i was
moving like no but
you're not you guys can't come right and
i explained it to them
now don't be silly like don't be silly
watch it from the pub
after the game like i was like obviously
real gutted and in my head i was like
like in my head i [ __ ] knew they
shouldn't have come like i knew they
shouldn't be coming
obviously it wasn't the reason we lost
the game well who knows obviously pretty
gutted but
yeah um it was it was like yeah it was
pretty tough
but yeah being able to see the boys you
boys do it the year after was
was unreal watched it with your brother
in england
and cheltenham and gloucester so it was
a pretty power moment to see you guys
do it yeah so you'd already signed for
gloucester at this time so
um what's what sort of brought that move
about yeah fine
i went over to go on india two of the
abs in 2014
and then my agent when i was over there
was like look there's a club
that's keen to have a chat um you know
like
you know it's no harm and just having to
sit down with them and you know seeing
what they
what they're about just you know you can
have a chat and i was i'm coming home
and hiring about it and i thought
yeah why not um we're over here might as
well go check it out and
have a chat to them and see what they're
all about and it was obviously uh
gloucester
and then i just was talking to him
and really enjoyed um what the director
of rugby
was trying to do it kind of seemed a
little bit like
where we kind of were in 2011-12 with
with the hurricanes they're trying to
you know take the team you know it was a
very proud club they had won a lot in
the past but they're
sort of in a tricky situation and trying
to move forward and and
you know start winning things again and
become a pretty um successful team so
kind of enjoyed where they were they're
taking things so i went home and
obviously my wife now uh girlfriend at
the time uh lucci was
had a good think about it and um yeah
obviously
had a verbal agreement with them over
new year's and 2000 of
2014 and then had to call
well i just thought it was a good thing
to do i called uh boardian
and steve to tell them what was
happening so that was a pretty
nerve-wracking
morning having to ring um those two two
guys to tell them that
um i've obviously made a decision that i
was going to leave after 2015 so it's
pretty
i get pretty anxious um kind of guy i
get a little bit nervous so i was pretty
you know just run things through your
head yeah so i was just running all
these scenarios of
different things trying to try to tell
them how it was going to go about so
um to be fair the the harder one was
woody in the end i was
nervous to ring steve um he was pretty
good about it
um obviously and um and then talking to
party yeah that was a bit of a tough one
in the end i didn't i thought that would
be the easier one
obviously because have a pretty good
relationship with him and and
you know like i guess you might have
thought that i might be coming to the
end in new zealand um
but it's quite quite tough i didn't know
you i don't think you saw it coming a
little bit and
yeah there's some pretty sweaty palms
making those two phone calls have you
always had a bit of anxiety throughout
your career and does that
sort of involve your game prep as well
or is that just
little things like phone calls and
hangover anxiety
oh yeah big fear big hangover fear that
anxiety
um but to do with the rugby yeah i
didn't even realize to be fair i had it
i remember the first year
playing for the canes like sometimes i'd
wake up
pretty early in the morning of the game
day we used to stay in hotels in new
zealand
back then um and sometimes i just wake
up
pretty early like four or five in the
morning and take a person and sit on the
edge of the bed thinking oh
[ __ ] like we're in a game today kind of
yeah i don't know maybe it was just
young and didn't really think too much
of it and
i just kind of went pretty well for the
first couple years so it didn't really
cause me too much trouble and then i
don't know i guess
uh there came a time where i just
realized that it was actually
affecting my performance a little bit
and
you know you play with me a fair bit
jimmy i realized if i can
get confidence from my week and i used
to take my week pretty seriously
back home that um if i can get like my
week sorted
that would give me the confidence to go
into the game and i could always like if
i started to get a little bit doubt or
the news did a bit too much of it well
now
you've done you've done the work during
the week right like yeah you're going to
be alright like it's going to be okay
so um i guess i yeah i put a real big
focus on
um making sure i got my weeks right and
had done the preparation and
there wasn't too many chances for me to
get
a lot of water anything in my head which
has been
it's helped a bit i guess yeah that's
good advice and do you have any advice
on how you handle your
hangover anxiety that's a big one for a
lot of listeners is it true that you
brought a puppy
hungover once with anxiety
most expensive mistake my life i think
here in perth with us
yeah we had a big night counting them uh
gloucester and then the misses and she
kept wanting to
what do they call them cavapoo skavoodle
or poodle king charles cavalier
oh it's oh it's where we're battling
we're both battling but she doesn't
really get the fair but i'd
get them oh i still do get the fair on a
hangover
we ended up going to worcester which is
not very far away but
we got this bloody little puppy and then
four months later i got told i've not
needed a gloucester anymore and had
somebody ship him over to
defer with me so it costs more than our
bloody furniture to get here so
um yeah it was um it was a really good
decision
before i get real quiet and then out of
nowhere just start asking heaps of
questions about what happened the night
before
oh classic i'll tell you that one of the
worst fears was the one after tojo's
buddy
of barcelona i don't think i recovered
until i got it was about a month after
we got to first i felt better after that
one that was a hell of a
hell of a weekend i don't think your
anxiety would have been as
bad as matt scott's
oh we're all up there i'll tell you what
we're all up there
in my airbnb review jesus that gave me
anxiety for
a few weeks oh if that was yeah
how cheap is it i had to delete my
account you know i'm glad we left so
early in the morning
karen fauna oh tony
anyway let's go back to rugby and
there's a massive part of your career
that we haven't even touched on yet is
your all black career
something which i sort of thought would
happen a little bit earlier than it did
did you ever feel like in those
selections leading up to before you were
selected that you
felt like you were going to be selected
um
we have so 2008 yeah first year uh
keynes and then played pretty well um
with the lines and there's obviously
like you know the media started talking
about a little bit and it was you know
people were saying oh you might go on
the india tour and kind of i kind of
fell off a little bit in the last three
or four weeks of that season with the
lines um
didn't play that well and kind of
started to get a bit fatigued a little
bit i think
um first proper full professional season
and
obviously thought like oh maybe i might
be with a chance i might take a couple
of young guys um
but missed out on that and then not
really i
like i was always hopeful but like i
never really strung a lot of
back-to-back performances and that were
worthy of being selected like i'd play
a good game and then have a couple of
you know all right quiet games and then
you know maybe a pretty crappy game and
then come back and play good like
in the years leading up and yeah i don't
know if that was part of figuring out
that i used to get you know a little bit
too nervous or worked up and getting my
own head a little bit too much
um and then i must have been off
contract
and maybe 2012 and i remember sitting
down with my agent and was just thinking
like
i i still feel like i can have a crack
here like i was a bit older i was
get coming in 26 27 um
and just i was there was obviously
people were keen to have me overseas um
a couple of clubs were interested and i
just thought if i left
and hadn't really given it my all like i
was like yeah
i'm going all right but i'm is there
more i can give to
you know fulfill the dream of becoming
all black and i remember
being like no no i'm just gonna i've now
resigned for another two years
um and finished 2012 and played a pretty
consistent
level through and then and really set
the world on fire anything but it just
had kind of got a bit of consistency in
my game that i was i guess i was lacking
and then to that year in the off season
instead of going away
i bought a house in wellington and
needed a bit of work on the outside so i
just stayed home and didn't
really have a holiday and had a couple
of builders that were living with me so
they helped
help me build a deck in the back of the
house and just trained and
thought you know i can crack on in 2013
and
really push for it and i guess i was
lucky i think harley william
said retired from professional rugby i
think and it had played reasonably well
again like consistency
and like i think sam whitelock broke his
thumb when they
picked the dune team so he was out for a
couple of weeks and remember being
heard we played we played the brumbies
over there and then after the game we
got told in the change rooms i think
that um
who had been named in the all blacks and
oh yeah i'd obviously got in
a jury replacement for sam white lock
and
yeah i was just like cool it kind of
all hit me to be fair like it'd been a
fair while like i remember in 2008 like
it's
same as when you asked if i'd thought
there's any pressure on me to
do anything after the the awarding when
i was a 19 year old yeah
i remember halfway through the 2008
super obvious season thinking
like i was going to write i was thinking
oh yeah that's right
they kind of pick an all black team from
playing flight
obviously just like like yeah yeah like
you know i mean i just i was just
enjoying playing footy and i think
for a while there after that 2008 year
i'd probably
maybe put too much on trying to find
that form again or find that to be
selected and in 2013 i just thought
i'm just going to give it a good old
shot and a good crack and really just
enjoyed it again and just had
a bit more fun i was always a pretty
intense guy you know that
training and stuff but i i was just
enjoying it and just i just had a fair
bit of fun
with it and i think obviously that was a
big part of
is me playing well it's just making sure
i try to have a bit more balance and
enjoy just playing the game instead of
being
a bit anxious about everything that
could go wrong or
why someone else is going better or
something like that and just focused on
on myself and it seemed to pay off which
was great how was your um
lead up to the debut against france
um good i had a bit of a test run the
week before i was on the bench at eden
park and i
actually feel pretty my brother flew
over from melbourne um
for the game obviously my mum and dad
were there my sister was there
so here we can't happened again didn't
get on but to be fair
i was pretty bloody nervous the whole
game where
it was probably and obviously the ab
coaches can pick up on probably things
like that and
i didn't get on that game it was
actually pretty close for a little bit
and i remember sitting there thinking
like i hope we actually like
push on here and i can get on because if
i have to go on
when it's close and a debut and i'm
sitting here like
i had like the lineups written on my
list and i
hadn't done that
oh yeah pretty disappointed but i was
like in the end
uh to be fair like i probably would have
like i wouldn't they would have been
fine but like i probably wasn't ready um
and then
got uh went down to christchurch and
obviously got picked on the bench again
um and we kind of got out to a
reasonably good lead there and got 15 i
think minutes off the off the bench
there and
it was unreal i remember just before i
went on like kind of just like was
pretty nervous again but
someone said something i don't know on
the bench and kind of had a smile
you know like there's no point like
you're here now like just
crack in and just ran around again like
i felt like i was
21 just trying to hit everything and
trying to do as much as possible and
in 12 minutes probably did nothing again
but uh
it felt like i was i was doing something
so it felt pretty good afterwards
yeah did your mum and dad go down to
that one they did they did
um classic stitch up that was the first
time um
they actually met uh luchi my wife or
was my girlfriend
then i asked her to come down and she
was oh who am i sitting with i was like
oh you're actually sitting with my mom
attack because that's the
tickets i could get uh next to him she's
like oh
cool like great so i think mum talked to
her most of the time and didn't really
watch much
i think she was more excited that i had
a girlfriend instead of
playing my first test match so mum was a
win-win for mum i think so she was
pretty happy
oh that's good stuff and then any
highlights throughout your all black
career that stand out to you
um definitely getting to play
uh the spring box in wellington at the
at westpac this was unreal um
got to start that game um my first start
down in
dunedin uh we obviously retained the
bloom's light with the fourth game
um we got to start that one and got
maybe 50
50 odd minutes which is pretty cool and
then
um scotland obviously um i didn't get a
lot of starts
um we had some probably two of the best
locks going around with
sam and brody and and then some decent
backups with
luke romano and some of those boys as
well obviously you know like
we're all fighting for for some time um
whenever i was in the squad
uh but playing scotland over there uh
was
was pretty unreal um just the way they
do things in the uk with test matches
was pretty cool they turned all the
lights off before the game and
yeah the bagpipes playing and and um
yeah like and then they'd obviously sing
the anthems and their songs
going through it was it was pretty
awesome but
just the whole experience like the whole
time i was there like
after that first sort of uh june series
and the first one came back and
obviously was pretty
nervous and and you know it had been a
long time to get into that team and
you're kind of walking around and don't
want to make a mistake and you end up
you probably end up not really enjoying
as much as you want to because
you're so worried about stuffing up or
whatever i came back and
just remember thinking if i get another
chance i'm just i'm just going to go in
and obviously
be a bit more myself and enjoy myself
and not worry about
[ __ ] things up all the time and and
just just get on with it and
and that was that to me there's just so
many cool experiences
that you get when you with that squad
from the things that they do as a team
together to
to what you can experience when you
travel um you know
the doors that opens and and people and
things you meet um
it's just pretty pretty cool and was the
goal always to make the 2015 world
cup squad was that the way you wanted to
finish your career in new zealand
yeah i guess it kind of ended up being
like that um
like so lucky we played scotland over
there
i played pretty well that game um
and then we played one more game um
after that
island i think i think and didn't get
picked for that one but
yeah and then was like well i've played
pretty well here like i've you know i've
done
pretty well when i've had my
opportunities uh especially in 2014
so i was like going to 15 and you know
crack on and
hopefully with with a bit of luck i can
i can make that team like
i never felt like my place was either
even like sealed or anything like that
but i was like if i worked hard and play
well again
and do that then hopefully i can have a
chance of um
you know going away on the world cup um
i've probably i reckon i probably put a
little bit too much pressure on myself
in that 2015 year with um
worrying about things again a little bit
i remember getting a call
halfway through the season um from
gilbert
anoka who's the mental skills guy and
does a lot of work with all the boys
around everything
um in the squad and chrono um
the forwards coach and i just could kind
of see that i
looked like i was too much in my head a
little bit didn't play as well
probably as i wanted to um and then yeah
obviously still got picked in the
championship team but only got
i think 10 15 minutes against argentina
before they named the world cup team
after that and they only took three
locks
in the end which was a little bit
disappointing but then
who knows they obviously said that you
know i was i was in there but
with a chance of someone fell over but
you know brodie had just
been playing unreal that year um for us
at the canes and got a chance to get his
debut
in africa with the abs and he was you
know playing over skin and
i think patrick might have had an
operation so that
knocked him out but like you know there
was other other other locks there that
we were still playing
really well so like i don't see like it
was like
i don't i'm not guarded or like upset
that i didn't get picked i can
understand
what they did and how they went about it
and yeah you know as i said like
you can never take the abs for granted
and i was grateful for the opportunities
that i did get within the team in
1314 and that final test and being
involved in the squad
before the world cup in 2015. so
that was awesome and was that a big part
of why you moved to gloucester in the
end just because
you felt like you sort of reached as
high as you could you didn't see
any more tests sort of coming on the
horizon i'm not too sure
i think obviously i was 30
obviously they had you know like sam and
brody who were younger than me that were
still
going really well um those guys coming
through and i just thought well you know
like
it's a good opportunity there's some
role with
being able to play overseas or sign a
contract
after 12 months after your last test
staff or something some rules so
the timing kind of worked out quite well
yeah with that
so i was like well if i get to sign
another year or two and don't
play for the abs again it might make it
harder to
get that opportunity to to hit overseas
and and experience something different
so
it kind of all just i felt at the time
fell into place a little bit for
a good wait a good way to finish um with
the hurricanes and
um maybe with the ids yeah and then talk
talk to me about your time over in
gloucester
how did you find it you were four years
over there you love it
i did i did i found it very very tough
in the first six months um i don't know
if it was because i'd
i went super rugby like a little bit abs
itm straight into it what is it
feels like uh 18 months uh competition
but what is that eleven ten months of
rugby in in the in the uk so by the end
of that season
i was i was pretty cooked um we didn't
go very well
or we weren't terrible but not how as
well as we wanted to and and i
i didn't feel like i had adapted as well
as i possibly could have to
the way that i play i i was probably
reasonably naive and
and how much different the game can be
from a tactical point of view and and
what they really put um
a focus on compared to new zealand and
especially the hurricanes
because even if a set piece was going to
where we had
backs and loose fords that could do
unreal things and
we could still be up by 30 points and be
at 25 position in territory yeah
so there was a lot of times i was like
obviously got a little bit um
frustrated with with the way we like the
boys saw the game and the way we played
it
um but got over there and and kind of
adapted and realized
it's just the way it is and and the way
they play and
and actually um after that first six
months like i loved it like we still
didn't go very well but
um i loved love being over over the uk i
love playing
at gloucester at king's home i just love
the the atmosphere of games like the
intensity
is up there it's a different type of
intensity to super rugby from
probably a speed point of view but from
like a contact and
and how close a lot of games are like um
that kind of intensity and what the
crowd brings to the games i think
is unreal was awesome
and learned a hell of a lot firstly
about
i guess myself um and
obviously being within the wellington
and the hurricanes environment for
10 years and plus with wellington a bit
longer
um going somewhere completely different
um
and being that different person over
there um
was was unreal and then just from a
rugby point of view just
how important i guess different things
are of different people from
from where you are in the world and how
to win games it was pretty cool it's
probably
the most i took out of it what was the
biggest shift for a lock
um going from super rugby to the english
premiership
um i guess for me i i was more like a
i'm more of like a support
to distribute sort of a lock i guess i'm
not a big
bulldozer tractor as they have over in
the uk so
um you know like uh i always thought
you'd
obviously play your strength so i had to
learn to you know there wasn't as much
opportunities for the support players
sort of part of the game it was more
really now your set piece you scrum your
line out um
a few hard carries um you know like
i always thought i wasn't really doing
too much in a lot of games because i
wasn't getting my hands on the ball from
a
phase pay point of view and yeah i was
thinking just like
they've obviously saw me here to do
things but i'm
not doing what i naturally like to do in
a game like it was a bit different so
i guess that was a big part of it and
then you would get the ball picked back
to us
like a box kick or whatever and i'll be
looking at a
full back thinking here we go like we
used to have you know you'd have andre
taylor
near him on a scatter or cj or something
like that at the back jimmy you
and you'd step two guys and we'd be back
on the 50 and they'll either kick it
back and you'd think oh [ __ ]
good game
yeah so from that point of view like uh
fullbacks probably normally got tackled
on their own 22 with the ball in hand
sort of thing so it was
a lot of backtracking to set up for
another box kick to get rid of it
so yeah yeah it was from that point of
view it was just
a whole different mindset that i had to
get around and
once i kind of figured it out and knew
that i'm still contributing to the team
probably not the way i wanted to with
the way i naturally play the game but
if i can get our set piece going all
right and
pick up a few carries and chase balls
and make some tackles then
you know like it you're actually doing
an alright job for your team sort of
thing so
yeah you obviously had some good times
off the field too over there
lots of lots of good stories over there
i got told one from my brother around
i think it was the end of season 2 where
you went and bought one of the biggest
burgers you could ever buy and
he actually threw it on top of him
slammed it on mark atkinson's head
and he was filthy he recognizes the
funniest thing he's ever seen
talk me through that one oh yeah so it
was funny because like you look back on
when we were there and we never we never
did
or when i was there we never did that
well in the english premiership but
there was the two european competitions
and
two out of three years we were there we
made the final obviously
lost both of them but mum and dad never
came to those ones so that throws that
bloody
idea out the window so it couldn't have
been much dad's fault we lost the 2015
flyer
but we have both of them it was a hell
of a shindig afterwards
so it was the first year uh inver
and then we went all night after that
game and then had a private flight home
it was like me your brother
james hook eki and stuff obviously
brought duty-free and snuck it onto the
back of the plane and
was asking for lemonades and having
vodkas and stuff and
hockey absolute lad you need to get him
on you won't understand what he's saying
and we're singing songs and everything
and we just kept kicking on
and ended up at one of the boys
restaurants out in gloucester keys and
i was so so drunk by then i thought that
we were the only ones in the place i
didn't realize there was families and
stuff on the other side
having lunch and ended up being dinner
and stuff and
yeah they brought out all these burgers
and i remember just i don't really
remember it too much i wasn't going to
pick up the tray and we were by the bar
by the end of it i was just like
sorry i was just like this would be
great there's no better person to be
able to throw this
burger at and just went and like flipped
it from the tray
yeah he must have docked something again
boys and just
almost hit like a family having like a
dinner at a table
by the bar and they were just like oh
and a whole
yeah i'll tell you what the fear the
next three days after that here's when
you brought the puppy
pretty big oh no that was uh
that was a couple years that was
mid-season as well so we've definitely
had a fair few
uh good blowouts uh along with along the
way which is great
you had to over there right because the
season was so long you couldn't just
wait till the end of season two you had
to
break it up a wee bit definitely but
that was great like
i guess one of the big things of being
overseas um
like i grew up in wellington so i was
always there and had friends
outside of rugby so you know i obviously
enjoyed
doing the things with the canes boys but
had that um
you know great group of friends from
school um
lads that you could just get away and
kind of be a bit normal with
um but over there like uh you know
the rugby teams are your friends and
family and um
you know got really close still are very
close
with with your brother and uh beth and
stuff and
uh matt scott scottish boy um and his
wife ruth so we had like a really good
little crew that was
most weekends ended up at our house
after games celebrate another
um another weekend through through the
footy
yeah yeah a few house parties and nights
out and shouting them so it was pretty
good
we had a hell of a lot of fun yeah good
times so then what what brought upon the
move to
western force um so johan eckerman took
over the
gloucester team um with in my final year
and he obviously brought in a fair few
sapphire boys which is
was fair enough he gave gaming early
enough warning that that was going to be
the plan and what he was about to do and
i really enjoyed working with him i
thought he was he was a great uh
great coach and um was really about
getting the team
cohesion really really good and strong
off the field and
and kind of i thought he did it
reasonably well like a lot of
players or coaches can come over from
the southern hemisphere and try to just
dump everything that you do and super
rugby into the northern hemisphere game
and
it doesn't really work that well but he
picked little things there
here and there that they did really well
the lines
that we tried to bring in and it kind of
showed that it worked the year after i
left because they
they made the semi-final so um i thought
that was pretty cool but yeah obviously
he
told me that they're going to sign a
couple of africans so he was kind of on
a hunt for a new contract
um somewhere and had a little bit of
stuff in france but yeah the force was
i kind of kept knocking on the door and
kept asking my agent if i was keen and
if i was wanting to come across and
i guess one of the big things after
being in the uk was we kind of wanted a
bit more of a
of a lifestyle um you know the better
weather or experience something a little
bit different
so that was a big thing one of the boxes
that we wanted ticked
um kind of wanted somewhere that was
that was really
keen to have me i guess the french teams
were sort of like yeah i
want you to come so from the lifestyle
point of view the france teams took that
box but
from really wanting to be able to make a
difference and help out
somewhere it didn't feel that that great
so i
decided why not like good good weather
in perth
um was pretty excited about what they're
trying to do i was obviously where am i
now almost 35
yeah so yeah it was two years ago so i
was still
going on 33 so obviously
the you know the style of rugby and what
they're going to do probably suited my
my body a bit more than staying up in
the northern hemisphere so
yeah i thought we just thought why not
and it's to be fair it's been great
um we've loved every minute of being in
perth it's been it's been an awesome
place to
live over the last three three years two
three years so yeah
and you've like we said at the start
you've made an instant
impression over there one thing i want
to talk to you about or ask you about is
over there the song adele talk to talk
to me about the adele theme song that
you
sing so well
honestly i was getting messages from all
over the place about
i was like what's going on here and then
it must have been a really slow day in
new zealand for news or something
because someone said it made the top
five stories on stuff or saying i was
like chief it's like
i never got that far up when i was it
didn't matter what i've done
so obviously it was a slow day in new
zealand news
people
every team has a song sort of guy that
leads a song after a game and
we've got a bit that's about the western
force at the start
and then he was like we're going to
change it up this year and we're going
to play a bit of a
banger or a song that everyone knows and
can sing along to
afterwards it'll just be a little bit of
the start of it and then
obviously the chorus and like we'll
finish it there so
could have been 10 or games since the
voice enforcer got a win
um over in sydney and we're all pretty
pumped and
no one realized the camera was still on
the change room and
it honestly honestly only caught me a
dell bit so
it's got all the boys getting pretty
deep into that so
i was going pretty hard and facing the
camera so obviously yeah got a little
bit of
media attention from there but it was um
it was pretty cool it was pretty funny
because no one was really sure how it
was going to go like
someone like you know everyone knows it
but like a bit of a weird song just
saying after the game
but the boys got stuck in and it was it
was pretty cool actually pretty funny
but you've got such a nice voice too you
can hear you could hear your voice
in the in the recording any chance of
giving us a wee
little teaser of the adele song you're
up there there
how's it going um oh come on i know you
know it
how's it going yeah no no no brain
freeze here
never mind i'll find someone like you
i wish nothing but the best
for you
don't forget
oh wow jeez for a moment there i thought
that was a dell that was so good
so if that doesn't make stuff i'll be
disappointed that was quality
what a voice you've been what have you
been
top five podcast for something you're
doing i'll definitely drop you down with
this one i think
i might be top story song
that was so good what a voice have you
always been a gifted singer
definitely
oh i love that anyway what are the plans
next is
singing singing part of it what's the
plans for big thrashy
the singing is uh hopefully well
i still keen to kick on um
at the moment my contract was only with
the force till the end of june or until
the end of trans tasman
hopefully we can we can play some of
those games it'll be good to
to get home and play some new zealand
teams and get some across
um but yeah i actually forgot how old i
was the other day i was driving home me
and cats which
were having a laugh about the other day
because he's the same age and i was in
the car and i was like
24 going on 35 and then realized no
i'm 35 going on 36 and i was like geez i
must be getting older
if i can't remember how old i am but i
would love to love to keep playing i
reckon i could go another
12 months hopefully yeah yeah so i'd
like to go
do something at the end of this if
hopefully the force will sign me for
next year or
pick something up um and i spoke to you
jimmy i'll be keen to get back and place
in my tm cup
if i could i think it'd be pretty cool
just to have one last little
stint in new zealand if someone was
crazy enough to
to sign me for for whatever it is three
months
tasman marco oh you'd be a great fit
you'd be a great fan
listen to some of the tessie boys that
you've had on here i'm not sure i'll be
able to keep up with it
that sounds like good lad it might be
the end of me if i came to the market
or the anxiety you have 10 puppies
um but yeah i'd love to i'd love to do
that if it came about
play another year of super or something
um
and then just see how i go but
i guess since leaving and
being at gloucester and being here i've
really enjoyed
like the the mental side of things with
some of the young guys we've had here
who haven't
ever been involved in a professional
setup um and just enjoying
um you know that sort of thing so i'd
love to
get into some sort of coaching with a
start with ford's uh
if it was an academy or something like
that along those lines or get over
somewhere
that's starting up a program somewhere
and and jump on that would be
would be a lot of fun and i'd really
enjoy that because i
i enjoy that now while i'm still playing
trying to help out some of the some of
the younger guys i guess
once i kind of left new zealand i had
more time and
didn't have to be i just felt like i was
pretty intense and focused really hard
on what i had to do
to be the best i could and probably
didn't give enough back to some
some boys back home which i probably
regret a little bit and
since i've left and been over here as
well i feel like i've
really tried to give a bit more back to
them and experiences that i've learned
along the way and try to help out that
way so
definitely be keen to get into stan and
rugby and help out
and and some involvement with with
coaching at some level
mate you would be you would be such a
good mentor
coach whatever whatever you decide to
choose you will be
one of the greats but anyway let's crack
on because we have so many questions and
as always we've gone to our instagram
for some questions
and thrashy the cult hero over in the
force
has come up with thousands we won't be
able to
we won't be able to ask them all but how
many abusive ones are there there must
be
a few abusive ones from that time
um first one oh this one this one's from
patrick gower
obviously a massive fan of yours love
your work great
how do you motivate yourself to
consistently be in the zone
i don't know i've probably only been
there once or twice in my life
um i don't know yeah as i i
think i touched on a bit serious here
but um
just i just i focus really hard on
getting
the week right for me personally if i
can get that right
i take away that nervousness and anxiety
on game day that used to take a fair bit
out of me
energy wise and and performance wise so
yeah that and then lately especially
last
maybe three or four years i used to
think like oh what's going to happen
65 minutes in and now i'm like
i might not even be on the field in 65
minutes so
i'll just enjoy the first five and see
how we go from there
taking away that kind of like what a
thought of things in the future it
definitely helps
overthinking yeah yeah overthinking is a
big problem
okay who was the best line-out operator
you came up against
um victor matfield definitely up there
with the bulls uh they had an unreal
cooperation uh mall and everything um
kieran reed
sam whitelock are bloody bloody pretty
smart
people when it comes to that
in the uk most line outs are pretty well
worked
um exit always had a pretty good one uh
sarasota so i guess that's george cruz
hitoji boys like that probably are
pretty up there with that sort of thing
as well
that's on top of my head some great guys
yeah yeah for sure
okay ask him how much he got paid when
he made the burger ring mini add
i had to google it i didn't know what he
was talking about
i did i saw it yesterday but i think in
the day there was a small mouth
burgering or the burgers in yeah so
there was a few boys that used to give
me a fair bit of [ __ ] back then about
that
yeah the big mo helps us probably
perpetuates his small mouth even more
helps with the big chin lady who knows
okay did you ever get this speaking of
being teased did you ever get teased at
school because of your surname
um yes not more just like comments
so from girls so it really didn't help
with my well i wouldn't say love life
but being able to talk to girls
um they would always be like oh who are
you like jeremy i was jeremy's like i
don't know why i'd always said my last
name but
for some reason sometimes oh no it's
because my mates
obviously called me and they'll be like
what like he goes about what and i'll be
like oh yeah my last name's thrash and
i'd be like
but um oh i had an older sister and i
never really thought about it too much
until
then and then like you're like wow [ __ ]
she must have had it pretty bad
if i was getting a little bit of it so i
feel pretty sorry for my sister
but obviously she's married into a new
name now so it doesn't have any of that
trouble
oh yeah i feel sorry for my daughter
um poor little girl so
it's her name's uh mia bella which in
italian is
my beautiful and their last name's
thrush so that's uh
that's not the best thing poor little
girl but hopefully she's got her mum's
mum's looks so and uh not too much of
her dad except for her last name
she'll be right too funny i never
thought about it until a little while
ago
true my dad always used to talk i never
picked up on it but dad always just said
when he answered the phone or
talked to people and had to give us his
full name he'd be like ian thrush and
he'll always be like like the bird
like the bird when i was younger i was
like
why did you always say that and then
obviously if i got older and found out
they had a different meaning i was like
fair enough it makes a lot of sense
speaking about luchi you've been
nominated in the new zealand rugby
list as the biggest puncher in world
rugby
standing out betting outside the creases
yeah yeah oh
how did you how did you guys meet how
did you fall um
well we actually had known each other
for a little while
all like knew um and had had friends
that were
sort of friends and crossed over a
little bit
um but she was obviously
she she lived out in eastbourne at a
young age as well but obviously we
didn't really know each other that well
then
um and then one year was in 2013
we're out one night and
got to got together and had some drinks
and stuff with a few other friends and
um and ridge square obviously ended up
um hooking up and the rest is history so
yeah i kept myself pretty lucky there to
be fair obviously she must have been
pretty drunk but
she doesn't know if i just keep putting
vodka in her water as it is now so she
just goes that way and keeps finding me
attractive so
it's worked out so far pretty well
okay what is the key to a good handlebar
moustache
oh probably a lot of surface area so
big jaw um where i've really had trouble
is
still still in there a little bit still
a little bit too blonde
falls out but i did have a i did shave
it into a goatee this year actually i
let it grow out
oh yeah um and it looked it looked quite
quite
quite good but i quite enjoy the
handlebars it's um
something a bit different um but um i
don't know yeah i guess
i've i've always been able to grow a
reasonably good beard so
yeah a little bit a little bit of uh
facial area to grow it and a dark i
think you need dark hair for a good hand
a good handlebar though yeah
itchy once i get past stubble
yours is yours is impressive holy heck i
love it
thinking for
see how that goes down i thought that'd
be that'd be pretty good oh it would go
down a tree it'd be good till i woke up
the next day with a hell of a lot of
fear
i love it okay well this is one thing i
didn't actually know about you but
you're obviously an
rnv legend because there's been a lot of
questions about your rmv times
how many times did you go and what was
your craziest
story from rnv um five
five times i think i ended up going
always good times last time i already
know i would have been
a little bit older i think i felt a
little bit too old by the time i left
but
just struck myself into feeling younger
again so it's pretty good
the a few a few crazy
stories that probably might have to wait
till i
finish playing i think i might get
myself a bit of trouble so
i can't elaborate too much there at this
stage unfortunately
sorry i can't wait for the sequel a few
good times
on the hill on the main main stand oh i
bet you're stuffing a bit of
a bit of stride so okay
have you ever been to hong kong any good
yarns yeah
with a friend to visit another friend
had a fair few good nights out there um
very interesting nightlife bit different
to
courtney place where i can see i can say
um the guy we went and visited a friend
and
short story was he told us like five
things not to do
and we woke up in the morning he had
done the opposite of
all five of those things you'd tick them
off yeah
oh so much fear
okay this one's from good mate of yours
tom savage
did you ever get your deposit back from
lansdowne
lodge and is the grass still green
um i did we did get up on back our
deposit back
we had a big driveway um when we lived
in gloucester and cheltenham
and stupidly enough told the boys to all
come back on the sunday
uh break up because we're at this pub in
cheltenham and it was getting
fairly rowdy and i still had a little
bit of common sense
left to me to think we stay here we
could be in a little bit of trouble so
see if we could all come back to our
place and just drink on the driveway
um probably not the best best idea
in the end um willie hinds's barbecue
got set on fire pretty big
um two couches ended up over the fence
at a doctor's practice and i woke up
i don't know how i woke up but i woke up
stuck
like upright at like six in the morning
and was like to luke she's like [ __ ]
and she's like what i was like the
couches are next door we've got to go
get them and like ran down the driveway
and had to lug these couches back down
the driveway
so yeah that was
it was pretty good pretty good night uh
afternoon but
yeah we still had like fire stains on
the driveway from
the boys oh getting up to no good joe
ladder another kiwi lad some of the boys
you probably know
put the lawn mower on and the garage and
started lawn mowering glass bottles so
we had to pick up a
bit of glass i think that's when lucky
called it actually she came out and saw
the fire
and the lawnmower going with glass
bottles being shredded everywhere was
came up to me and was like i think you
guys need to go and i was like yeah
i think we need to go so i think after
that we
we ended up heading off and going into
town which is
probably not a good idea either but it
was all right that is
loose that is
very very loose grass is green oh
the grass is green so
one must have been the second year we
we lost we're up by like 20 odd points
and we ended up losing
in the last minute so i was like in my
head i'm like i don't think we're
mentally that strong as a as a team so
i thought i'd incite the boys on a bit
of things i'd learnt from
times of the hurricanes and the abs
about mental mental toughness and
i was like one of the you know one thing
i always tell myself like tell the boy's
name
like standing up here you just stayed a
fact to get yourself out of that bad
time
so i was like like the grass is green
right the grass is green and it takes
your mind out of that negative spiral
floor
and the boy is just like every training
like i'd lose my shift or something and
they'd be like the grass is green
oh i love those things
oh yeah
like the english is so much i found that
the english of
such good banter compared to where we
had the canes right
you just no one is safe or nothing is
off
limits constant a it was pretty funny it
was pretty good time
yeah yeah it just doesn't stop okay
this one how much do you love usain bolt
um what was it 300 pounds
that's how much i love them 300 pounds
worth
what what's that story about a drinking
story
so last year at gloucester all the
injured boys
i think the team went to exit to play
and we had like it was like
125 years or something and it was
um like it was like a dinner
auction dinner but raising money and all
the injured boys went and obviously
shocked tojo your brother was injured
again and so was i so
we went and it was like black tie event
and we're at this table and
we're a few deep with the other boys i
was like all right we
everyone has to like bid on something so
like
you have to bid on it and like i was
like trick is to get in early
and it was just i don't know if it was
his was a signed picture of you same
boss
and like i wasn't really listening i
think someone had
vetted like something and then i was
like i gotta get in i put my hand up now
like 300
to jeremy and i was like holy [ __ ] like
that's a fair bit of money
and no one else did it and they were
like going by
300 pounds the journey i was like
i had to like write my name down and
like my number so they had to
call me to pay for it went away with a
picture of a signed picture of usain
bolt that
probably wasn't worth anything um
one of the boys ollie thorley's got it i
gave it to him and
and gloucester right he's got it that
was a leaving gift for him
just brought back memories oh yeah
yeah i just sat in the garage for like
six months and just fighting
like thinking leslie bonacolo turned up
to that um
dinner and he's a gloucester legend and
i was like
the volcano it's like obviously new
playing for
like the kiwis in league and like me and
tojo ended up going out with him and
like he's still he hasn't been in
chat no more for years and like all the
pubs and clubs like would just give him
a bottle vodka over the bar and
like there you go mate like feel free
to tojo took me home i still have no
idea
what happened in town with the volcano
and still one of the best best nights of
my life
oh what a legend what a lad my tux was
in a
mess yeah yeah it was awesome
oh geez some good yarns okay
high or stream this one's from blair
cowan good what a lead man
butler high school of course that was
like a claim to fame
uh high b silver stream two years or two
times that year
which is hasn't happened it never
happened in years so
um i'm pretty sure raro cried on the
field after the game at
okay last question
what was the best piece of advice that
jeremy thrush received throughout his
career
don't say the grass is green the grass
is green
um i don't know
i i don't know if there's there's heaps
you know i mean you get little things
even out again or every year that
that help but i think looking back now
like if i was gonna
tell a young jeremy thrush what to
to be better at but probably be like
especially in new zealand like don't
be so highly strong um
within everything like just balance like
yeah i look back now there's
so many cool times and awesome things
that
like within the cage or wellington or
whatever but like
i probably didn't embrace them or enjoy
them as as well as i could have because
obviously i had goals and was so worried
about
trying to make make teams or or achieve
those goals that
i probably didn't really enjoy myself as
much as i probably could have from
enjoying those moments within team
environments as much
i feel like i'm at a better place with
that now um
since i left new zealand i don't know if
it was just because i put a lot of
expectation on myself
um like within the hurricanes and and
the lines to
to obviously try to win something with
those teams um or not
but yeah that's probably the thing i'd
if i could go back in time and tell
the young jerry to just probably enjoy
yourself a bit more
yeah how would you do that i don't know
i you you know what it's like that like
new zealand's such like a a fishbowl
kind of place when it comes to rugby
like
you play badly and you go out the next
day for lunch or something and
obviously everyone knows obviously kind
of who you are and
you guys didn't play that well and
you're looking at them and
i used to think like shitty sticking
like there was [ __ ] yesterday yeah i
mean like stuff like that and like
like i just kind of no i didn't even
really worry i didn't really have
social media that much like so that
didn't really bother me um it was more
like
you know just what what i came into with
the lions and hurricanes and where we
where we've got to and where i wanted us
to get to that you know i just i was i
put a lot of pressure
i guess on myself and and wanting things
to
to be good and better than when i first
came into the team and
and i don't know maybe i got away from
it
enjoying it as much as i probably could
have um from that point of view
and you know yeah yeah i don't know like
it's just once i left and
got to gloucester i almost didn't have
those expectations as much on
i could just play club rugby for for the
team
yeah that you're playing for like
there's there's no other no other things
there like
um no other high orders or that you know
that other goal it was just
go out there and play as well as you
could for for gloucester
and enjoy it and and move on to the next
week sort of thing
i probably should have if i could have
had that
um had that more as a as a hurricane and
as a line because
as i said it probably helped me play
better when i just tried to
not worry about trying to be an all
black again or be an all black or
anything like that so
yeah oh that's good stuff you are going
to be such a good mentor oh
can't wait to see you in the mental game
that's such good advice for a young lot
coming through
just just relax don't overthink poor
kids
that wraps up the podcast obviously i
love playing with you in my time with
the hurricanes mate you're an absolute
champion bloke had some awesome times
over
in the uk with you as well obviously you
were very close with my brother so we
we ended up having a few good do's
together and mate you're such a good lad
um looking forward to you joining up
with the itm cup this year hopefully
with tasman and looking forward to you
running around back in new zealand that
would be awesome to see
at the ripe old age of 36 and still
going strong but
what a career what a journey and what a
lad really appreciate you giving up your
time and coming on the waterlab podcast
cheers jimmy it's been awesome hopefully
i haven't rambled on too much for you
mate and you can get something good out
of it
oh mate so much quality in that
appreciate it
no worries good to see you